bonjour journal justement on va parler
numérique avec vous est-ce qu'on sera
bientôt remplacé parce que je serai
peut-être remplacé dans quelques années
par tchadjipiti ou comme ça une
intelligence artificielle c'est pas de
la science-fiction vous ne serez pas
remplacé parce que il y a une différence
majeure entre l'intelligence humaine et
l'intelligence artificielle c'est que
l'intelligence humaine elle est doublée
d'une volonté il n'y a pas de volonté
artificielle et donc là où
l'intelligence artificielle pourra nous
aider pourra compléter le travail que
nous faisons elle ne pourra pas nous
remplacer mais dans le sujet qu'on vient
de de voir il y a évidemment une
question qui se pose c'est la juste
rétribution des auteurs de créateurs de
contenu originaux qu'il va falloir
régler pour que l'intelligence
artificielle soit soutenable et pour
pouvoir continuer à soutenir la création
alors vous présenter tout à l'heure en
conseil des ministres un projet de loi
pour je cite sécuriser et protéger
l'espace numérique vous souhaitez par
exemple mettre en place un filtre
anti-arnac toutes les semaines c'est
vrai comme des millions de Français moi
je reçois effectivement plusieurs SMS
par exemple de l'assurance maladie soit
disant l'assurance maladie qui me
demande effectivement
de renouveler ma carte vitale avec à la
fin effectivement la carte bleue qui est
demandé est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
mettre fin à ce fléau avec un simple
filtre oui la sécurité elle progresse de
jour en jour elle sape la confiance de
nos concitoyens dans le numérique tous
les Français sont concernés nous avons
tous reçu les SMS que vous évoquez nous
avons tous hésité à cliquer 18 millions
de Français ont été victimes de
cyberatta que l'année dernière et la
moitié ont perdu de l'argent au passager
souvent ce sont les Français les plus
fragiles les plus démunis les plus
éloignés du numérique qui sont spoliés
ou entraînés dans la spirale infernale
de l'usurpation d'identité donc avec un
filtre vous allez réussir à régler ce
problème avec un filtre pour couper le
mâle à la racine en dévitalisant le
commerce de ces pirates 100 fois ni loi
qui ont fait de nos smartphones nos
téléphones portables qu'on a dans la
poche l'instrument de leur raquette ça
sera un dispositif simple et gratuit qui
prémunira les internautes lorsqu'ils
s'apprête à se diriger sur un site
malveillant c'est-à-dire un site conçu
pour piller nos données personnelles
numérique de tout connaître pour que ce
filtre fonctionne non ce sera simplement
vraiment il sera généralisé et il nous
évitera de nous rendre sur ces sites
malveillants pour y déposer des
coordonnées bancaires ou des données
personnelles et vous savez que ce sont
des organisations criminelles parfois
mafieuses qui sont effectivement
derrière ces trafic de donner ses
arnaques est-ce qu'on peut vraiment avec
un filtre avec toute la bonne volonté du
monde on voit que vous êtes
effectivement très déterminé mettre fin
contourner bloqué ces organisations
criminelles que font ces organisations
criminelles elle lance de grandes
campagnes de faux SMS de faux mail en
espérant pouvoir collecter ainsi de très
grand nombre de données personnelles de
donner bancaires avec ce filtre dès
qu'une personne aura été touchée par par
le début de l'attaque et bien le filtre
s'activera et prémunira les tous nos
concitoyens les autres contre cette
attaque et ce faisant le filtre
découragera les criminels de s'attaquer
à la France puisqu'il sera beaucoup
moins rentable pour eux de le faire
désormais le site de l'Assemblée
nationale attaqué et effectivement
quelques mois par un piratage le site du
Sénat quand la semaine dernière
également et ça ça peut être que la
phase immergée de l'iceberg maintenant
plutôt ce sont des satellites qui
pourront être détournés par des
puissances étrangères par ce genre de
piratage très puissants notamment la
Russie bien sûr est-ce que nous sommes
un petit peu naïf face à ces sujets face
à ces menaces comme le disait Raphaël
Glucksman qui était notre invité hier à
votre place au 4 V vous avez évoqué
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat vous
auriez pu parler de l'hôpital de
Corbeil-Essonnes l'hôpital de Versailles
la Région Guadeloupe la région de la
ville de Caen de Chaville ou de Lille
quand tout était victime d'une
cyberattaque depuis l'été dernier avec
ce filtre de cybersécurité anti-arnac
nous allons dévitaliser les stratégies
conduites par ces cybercriminels pour
attaquer nos organisations puisqu'il
s'appuie sur nos sur les données
personnelles des collaborateurs des
agents pour s'infiltrer dans ces
organisations mais par ailleurs en 2021
dans le cadre du plan de relance nous
avons lancé un programme de
cybersécurité des grandes collectivités
des établissements hospitaliers des
établissements public ce plan est en
train de se mettre en oeuvre nous
l'avons renforcé cet été suite à
l'attaque commise sur l'hôpital de
Corbeil-Essonnes et c'est ainsi que nous
protégerons mieux nos hôpitaux nos
mairies
forcément les mairies parfois il y a
qu'un seul employé c'est pas avec une
secrétaire d'Amérique vous allez faire
face à une menace russe par exemple vous
avez raison et pour les plus petites
collectivités ce à quoi nous travaillons
avec l'ancien notre agence nationale de
sécurité des systèmes d'information
c'est une solution sur abonnement
sécurisée vers lesquels les petites
communes pourront se tourner pour
disposer d'un nom de domaine et d'une
messagerie qui sera parfaitement
sécurisée de plus en plus de jeunes gens
Noel Barrault pas seulement également
des moins jeunes des personnalités
également sont harcelées quotidiennement
sur les réseaux sociaux parfois avec des
phénomènes de meute c'est illégal on le
sait et pourtant beaucoup le font avec
un sentiment d'impunité totale il y a
quelques rares condamnations on a vu
l'affaire Mila et Eddy De Pretto par
exemple qui ont des condamnations c'est
quand même une goutte d'eau face à la
meute de harcèlement aujourd'hui sur
Internet vous l'avez dit on ne compte
plus les victimes
les influenceurs c'est vrai que c'est
des actions pas là qui paraissent un peu
loi mais ces influenceurs parfois ils
font des effectivement des choses
répréhensibles des arnaques peut-être
plus grave on l'a vu effectivement avec
une affaire dont on a parlé beaucoup la
semaine dernière et face à ça il y en a
certains qui se font un peu justice
eux-mêmes je vous parlais d'un rappeur
vous connaissez peut-être Booba il s'est
fixé comme mission dénoncer les
agissements de ces influenceurs qu'il
appelle des influx voleur dénoncer ses
parceler dit Booba et pourtant là aussi
on lâche les meute on lâche la meute
forcément quand on comme ça pointe du
doigt les agissements de quelqu'un
puisque vous parlez des influenceurs
plutôt que de vous répondre sur Booba
directement simplement dire que le Sénat
a adopté une mesure qui vient traiter
les problèmes qui sont liés à 1% des
influenceurs dans 99% des cas il n'y a
pas de problème et ceux qui vendent en
gros des arnaques ce qui est produit
malveillants ceux qui vendent d'ailleurs
volontairement ou involontairement ceux
qui sont les instruments des arnaques
mais dans 99% des cas les influenceurs
c'est une activité nouvelle qui apporte
un certain nombre de bénéfices aux
Français parce que il faut encadrer il
faut donner un statut il faut protéger
les influenceurs qui ce qui sont sur le
droit chemin sanctionner ceux qui sont
des cartes et puis faire en sorte que
les Français puissent avoir confiance
dans les affaires justice soi-même je
veux dire quand effectivement on voit
des agissements qui ne sont pas
conformes comme le fait Booba mais comme
d'autres est-ce qu'on peut comme ça se
dire non se comportement il est pas
normal parce que forcément la justice va
trop lentement à côté il ne faut jamais
se faire justice soi-même c'est la
raison pour laquelle on pose des cadres
de façon à ce que chacun puisse se
comporter en responsabilité il y a les
influenceurs effectivement qui sont très
suivis qui vendent des produits il y a
aussi d'autres comportements et des
d'autres sites qui ont des comportements
là qui ne sont en dehors du cadre je
vous parlais des sites pornographiques
accessibles aux mineurs en quelques
clics tout le monde le sait tout le
monde le constate il y a déjà une loi
qui est en vigueur n'importe qui
malheureusement peut aujourd'hui avoir
accès à des contenus interdits aux moins
de 18 ans parfois violents en quelques
clics les sites ne vérifient pas l'âge
des utilisateurs on continue comme ça
vous avez raison et les enfants sont les
grandes victimes de ces désordres qu'on
rencontre dans la société numérique
c'est 2 millions d'enfants qui sont
exposés chaque mois à des contenus
pornographiques parce que vous l'avez
dit les sites ne vérifient pas l'âge de
leurs utilisateurs alors qu'ils y sont
tenus par la loi il y a une procédure
judiciaire en cours qui applique 5 des
principaux sites le verdict sera rendu
en juillet et j'espère qu'il sera
exemplaire mais pour l'avenir je propose
que nous puissions taper plus fort plus
vite en donnant à l'arcom l'Autorité de
régulation de l'audiovisuel et de
l'Internet le pouvoir de bloquer et de
déréférencer sur les moteurs de
recherche les sites pornographiques
vérifieront pas l'âge de leurs UTS de
justice c'est l'art comme qui pourra
bloquer sans passer par une condamnation
de justice de manière à ce que le
blocage pure un puisse intervenir en
quelques semaines seulement donc s'il y
en a signalement d'un site qui ne
vérifie pas à l'âge des utilisateurs
l'art comme peut le
bloquera en demeure pendant 15 jours le
site concerné et s'il ne sait pas mis en
conformité avec la loi alors il sera
bloqué et le ça deviendra posteriori le
juge interviendra si le site fait appel
pour pour obtenir réparation il y a des
voies de recours qui sont prévues mais
c'est bien l'arcom qui en quelques
semaines pourra ordonner le blocage du
site une question pour finir Jean-Noël
baroué il paraît que le job de ministre
ne fait plus rêver vous aurez 40 ans
dans quelques jours bon anniversaire
d'avance est-ce que vous voyez à votre
poste encore comme ça jusqu'à votre
retraite et juste peut-être jusqu'à la
fin de votre carrière comme c'était le
cas par exemple pour votre paie ou
encore votre grand-père écoutez je
présente ce matin un projet de loi vous
êtes dans l'action que que nous allons
enrichir et renforcer au Parlement vous
voyez en politique toute votre vie
vous savez c'est la question
l'engagement j'ai eu une vie avant la
politique j'ai été enseignant et
chercheur j'y étiré beaucoup de plaisir
et ce que j'y ai appris je l'ai emmené
avec moi dans mon engagement politique
ensuite mon engagement politique ne va
jamais me quitter en de se défait pas de
ses valeurs de ses idéaux ceci étant dit
il y a beaucoup de choses que il y a
beaucoup de manières de servir son pays
la politique en est nuque en est une il
y en a d'autres merci Jean-Noël barre au
ministre délégué chargé du numérique
l'invité des quatre vies ce matin bonne
journée